most of the film and video we watched
these days is short form and these next
nominees are pushing the possibilities
of that Medium to its fullest it feature
films like Nobles short films are like
poetry you've got to distill all that
emotion suspense and impact write down
to a fraction of the length here are the
nominees for best live action in short
film
an Irish goodbye Tom Barkley and Ross
white
he followed Anders Walter and Rebecca
Cruzan
in Alfonso
Knight Pride ivik Triton and garter lead
Larson
the red suitcase Cyrus neshvat
and the Oscar goes to
an Irish goodbye
some Berkeley and Ross white
Tom Berkeley voiced Prince Harry's
thoughts in a TV documentary Ross white
hails from Belfast the filming location
of an Irish goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
very me um
thank you so much the academy for this
incredible incredible honor thank you to
our fellow nominees all the nominees for
your own work your work that inspires us
so very very much
thank you to everybody back home in
Northern Ireland who helped us make this
film we wish we had the time to list you
all here but you know who you are
um
there's something very important I'd
like to speak about as well
this award is actually the second most
important thing about today because it's
this man's birthday
is out here in Hollywood wearing a
leopard print suit jacket
uh we'd love to use the rest of our time
up here to sing for James
[Applause]
[Music]